n
lieu historique. Ça va changer.
- Cette maison a vu grandir
René-Lévesque jusqu'à
ses 14 ans. Elle est désormais
la propriété de Québec :
une nouvelle qui réjouit
Louis Bernard. Avec la Fondation
de la Maison René-Lévesque,
il a consacré plusieurs années
à tenter d'acquérir cette
résidence afin d'en faire
un lieu rendant hommage
au politicien. Faute d'avoir pu
s'entendre avec le propriétaire,
l'organisation s'est plutôt
lancée dans le projet
de création de l'Espace
René-Lévesque, inauguré
à New Carlisle en 2019.
LOUIS BERNARD, prés. Fondation
maison René-Lévesque 2012 à 2019
- Il n'est pas trop tard, mais
ce que ça va permettre, ça va
permettre aux visiteurs d'ici
ou aux autres visiteurs qui
viennent à New Carlisle de voir
la maison de René Lévesque.
Si c'est pour la visiter,
c'est une autre paire de manche
parce que si on veut faire
rouler du public là-dedans,
il y a des exigences.
- Le ministère de la Culture
a l'intention de procéder
à un bilan de l'état des lieux,
qui nécessite une importante
cure de jouvence,
puis de procéder aux travaux
nécessaires à la conservation
et à la mise en valeur
de la maison. C'est ensuite
que seront analysées
les vocations potentielles.
La nouvelle de la sauvegarde
du bâtiment, qui a demandé
beaucoup de temps, suscite
de la satisfaction,
mais aussi des attentes.
SYLVAIN ROY,
député de Bonaventure
- René Lévesque a marqué
l'histoire du Québec et beaucoup
de gens se demandaient pourquoi
la maison était en si piètre
état. C'est sûr que là, on entre
dans une restauration, on entre
dans une phase qui va coûter
des sous. Ça va être
dispendieux, mais en même temps,
le monsieur le mérite.
JEAN-MARIE FALLU, historien
- Par ailleurs, le gouvernement
actuel, je me réjouis qu'il
l'ait achetée. Maintenant,
j'espère que la mise en valeur
de la maison va se faire de
façon concertée avec le milieu
et non de la façon dont on a mis
en place, par exemple,
les espaces bleus.
- Le 16, rue Mount Sorel a été
reconnu monument historique
en 1995 par le gouvernement
péquiste de Jacques Parizeau.
Ici Roxanne Langlois,
Radio-Canada, New Carlisle.